but we begin here in selma alabama this
morning with the formal remembrance of
an american hero
congressman john lewis the civil rights
icon died last week at the age of 80.
lewis was a leader of the freedom riders
and a protege of martin luther
king jr in a struggle to fight against
racial segregation lewis often faced
arrest and violence this morning lewis's
body left atlanta to come here to
alabama
the nearly week-long celebration of his
life starts this morning
with services in his hometown of troy
alabama
his body will be to then be taken here
to selma alabama site of the 1965 civil
rights march
that ended in bloody sunday tomorrow a
procession will carry lewis across the
edmond pettus bridge
in selma his body will lie in state in
alabama's state capitol tomorrow night
and in the u.s capitol on monday and
tuesday
before making one final trip back to
atlanta
where he served as a congressman for
more than 30 years
a final tribute to lewis is scheduled on
thursday at the ebenezer baptist church
the same church once led by his mentor
dr king
john lewis will cross the edmond pettus
bridge
one last time 55 years after bloody
sunday
his casket will make a final symbolic
journey
across the alabama river and on to
montgomery
to lyon state the history of this region
cannot be
told without lewis and all the other
civil rights
champions who fought with such steadfast
passion
when was the first time you met john
lewis kenta fulford is selma's new
police chief
a local cop who came up through the
ranks
he paved the way for us and i think it
is my duty by responsibility to
continue in his footsteps to show people
that hey
it doesn't always have to stay the same
and everyone has to make a difference
later today lewis will travel over the
country roads to his hometown of troy
alabama for a memorial service at the
university there
lewis wanted to attend the then whites
only college
but the school ignored his application i
tell you
in so many different ways i'm honored
and happy to be here
two years ago there was reconciliation
as the school celebrated john lewis day
and unveiled an historical marker dr
jack hawkins is the university president
the institution denied admission
yet later saw fit to give him an
honorary doctorate
we'd be proud of the latter terry sewell
represents selma
in the u.s congress she called lewis a
friend
a mentor and a father figure
she will help lead sunday's march to the
bridge
the irony is that the first time john
did a march from selma to montgomery
he was met at the foot of the bridge
with billy clubs
and that march from selma to montgomery
was contentious
he was clearly not invited into the
state capitol
now he will get a hero's welcome which
is what he deserves
this is personal for you very personal
it's not often you get to meet your own
hero
it's rare let alone to give a give it
get an opportunity to sit at his speed
and learn from him
to walk in the footsteps of john lewis
with john lewis
that's a treat of a lifetime and i got
to do it over and over again
over and over again in washington d.c
where she says so many people were
touched
by his kindness the subtlety of his
mentorship
and certainly here in selma alabama
where you have
people walking down the street who have
their own personal stories this man
really touched so many people dana and
jeff michelle that's been the amazing
thing is seeing how many people he
touched over the last week i've even
heard from friends who lived in his
district and met him just one time
with their stories he really had such a
huge impact